wir müssen heute über etwas reden was
ist eigentlich gar nicht geben system
staatsversagen
großes wort aber wie soll man das sonst
nennen was wir da in den letzten wochen
und monaten erleben dass ins chaos des
bildungs chaos der korona panini die
tatzeit als erstes
bundesverfassungsgericht der
bundesregierung erklären muss wie man
klimaschutz macht die flut und dann das
desaster in afghanistan ich glaube dass
bei all diesen verschiedenen problemen
ein tief sitzendes problem die ursache
ist und das wollen wir heute es genauer
anschauen am beispiel der ortskräfte in
afghanistan die wir gerade im stich
lassen
ich bin thomas reichert und ich frage
mich was ist das überhaupt
staatsversagen staatsversagen ist wenn
der staat elementaren aufgaben nicht
nachkommt das was wir per se eigentlich
immer haben ist der start für unsere
sicherheit für unsere gesundheit für
unsere bildung sorgt staatsversagen ist
also das gegenteil und es bedeutet auch
dass die legitimität für den start der
glaube an die demokratie schaden nimmt
und genau das ist passiert in
afghanistan mit den orts kräften es sind
kann die deutschen bundesbürger das
stimmt schon viele jedenfalls nicht aber
sie haben jahrelang manche
jahrzehntelang für uns gearbeitet für
unsere sicherheit gesorgt die der
bundeswehrsoldaten in afghanistan und
jetzt haben wir sie im stich gelassen um
zu verstehen welches drama da passiert
ist schauen wir diesmal nicht nach
afghanistan sondern vor allem nach
berlin auf das was da vor und hinter den
kulissen alles abgelaufen ist alles
beginnt mit der april als joe biden
amerikanische präsident erklärt dass die
amerikaner nun wirklich und tatsächlich
aus afghanistan abziehen werden und das
bedeutet auch wir deutschen die
bundeswehr wird abziehen ende april
fährt heiko maas der deutsche
außenminister nach afghanistan mein
kollege andreas künast hat ihnen damals
begleitet und die bilder die haben es
mit dem wissen von heute wirklich in
sich deutschland sieht mit sorge wie die
amerikaner das interesse an afghanistan
verliehen das ist vor allem eins wichtig
dass das was hier in den 20 jahren
aufgebaut worden ist auch mit der
internationalen truppenpräsenz
dieses land weit vorangebracht hat und
deshalb
ist das nicht umsonst gewesen angesichts
solcher bilder stellt sich die frage war
der afghanistan-einsatz umsonst sie wird
nicht heute und nicht von den deutschen
beantwortet sondern erst wenn sie
wechselt in den ganzen wochen danach ist
heiko maas bei seiner haltung geblieben
noch anfang juni erklärt er im bundestag
dass eine machtübernahme der taliban
nicht drohe all diese fragen haben wir
die grundlage dass in wenigen wochen die
taliban in afghanistan
das zepter in der hand haben das ist
nicht die grundlage meiner annahme wer
ein problem nicht sehen will der sorgt
natürlich auch nicht dafür dass es
gelöst wird als die bundeswehr ende juni
aus afghanistan abzieht nimmt sie einen
schweren riesigen gedenkstein mit für
die toten bundeswehrsoldaten wofür sie
nicht sorgt ist dass alle ortskräfte
ebenfalls mit nach deutschland kommen da
schaffen bis zu diesem zeitpunkt nur
knapp 2000 das ist aber nur ein kleiner
teil von all denen die hilfe bräuchten
das sind die letzten deutschen truppen
aus afghanistan zurückkehren und fällt
euch was auf wer fehlt auf diesem bild
genau die verteidigungsministerin fehlt
und die kanzlerin so darf ich doch als
ihr kommandeur für sie verstellen
mission accomplished
sie haben ihren auftrag erfüllt dass
angela merkel ist nach 20 jahren einsatz
in afghanistan es nicht für nötig hält
die letzten truppen persönlich in
empfang zu nehmen erzählt viel darüber
wie wenig sie offensichtlich selbst mit
afghanistan zu tun haben will das ist
einerseits ein schlag ins gesicht der
bundeswehr soldaten und andererseits
erweist es sich als vorteil für die
afghanischen ortskräfte die genau in
diesem moment die hilfe von angela
merkel bräuchten halten wir fest die
bundesregierung redet sich über wochen
die lage in afghanistan ist schön und
die ortskräfte die sind ganz sicher
nicht top priority zu diesem zeitpunkt
wie wenig sie das sind das merkt man
kurz darauf im bundestag da bringen
grüne und linke anträge ein für eine
schnelle aufnahme der afghanischen
kräfte und die anträge werden abgelehnt
von union und spd der groko weil es in
diesem moment wichtiger ist offenbar
anträge der opposition diesen
wahlkampfzeiten abzuschmettern als den
ort kräften zu helfen und auch jetzt
rechtfertigen union und spd dieses
abstimmungsverhalten immer noch ja ich
habe dagegen gestimmt aber es geht auch
nicht da weil es nicht darum geht das in
das wir anträge beschließen sondern es
ging darum dass die regierung so handelt
dass sie ihren schutz verantwortung
gerecht wird das wird nicht in den
anträgen im bundestag beschlossen
sondern das ist
hätte sein müssen das aktuelle
regierungshandeln daran hat es gefehlt
es ist von der regierung entschieden
worden dass wir die ortskräfte
herausholen dass es exekutives handeln
und deshalb ist auch ein verfahren wie
die ortskräfte bestimmt werden können
wie sie wiesen bekommen können
festgelegt worden zwischen den
zuständigen ministerium in berlin wird
da viel geredet und wenig getan viel
zeit verstreicht bis
es zu spät ist kommt euch bekannt vor
von corona vom klima vielleicht auch von
der flut ganz genau genauso ist es bei
den afghanischen kräften und wieder geht
es um menschenleben egal mit welchem
ministerium ich in diesen tagen
telefoniere jeder erklärte jahr bei den
treffen da waren wir schon seit ende
april dran stimmt ja auch keiner hat
sich aktiv gewährt keiner gesagt die
ortskräfte kommt mir nicht ins haus hat
großen widerstand geleistet aber kein
ministerium ist auch entschlossen voran
gegangen und hat dafür gesorgt dass die
ortskräfte wirklich gerettet werden man
hat geredet zwischen den ministerien dem
für inneres dem für äußeres dem zur
verteidigung und dem für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit über ein sogenanntes
ortskräfte verfahren und es gab auch
eine innenministerkonferenz die sich
ebenfalls dafür aussprach die ortskräfte
aufzunehmen
alles gut
nein denn es wurde zwar viel geredet was
es aber nicht gab waren entscheidungen
handel ein beispiel dass ich mit
bekommen wird die bundeswehr will ende
juni 60 ortskräfte aus masar i scharif
ausfliegen mit ihren familien sie
startet dafür flugzeuge
bereitet einiges vor und stornierte
flüge dann wieder warum das habe ich die
bundeswehr gefragt ob sie hat mir
geantwortet dass zu dem geplanten
durchführungs zeitpunkt konnten die
voraussetzungen wie passt und visa für
die sichere abfertigung der möglichen
passagiere vor ort nicht mehr erfüllt
werden das heißt es gab probleme auf
afghanischer seite aber eben auch auf
deutscher seite hin insbesondere das
innenministerium wollte eine
sicherheitsüberprüfung der afghanen
haben und auch die frage wo sie ihre
deutschland dieser bekommen war nicht so
schnell zu klären warum eigentlich nicht
dann fällt mit zwei wochen später im
brief der menschenrechtspolitische
sprecher von linke fdp und grünen auf es
ist ein dramatischer appell an die
kanzlerin
darin heißt du sehr geehrte frau
bundeskanzlerin die bundesregierung und
auch sie ganz persönlich stehen in
politischer die moralische verantwortung
für diese menschen ohne die der
schwierige und gefährliche einsatz der
bundeswehr in afghanistan schlicht nicht
möglich gewesen wäre und sie fordern
dass es endlich endlich eine regelung
für diese afghanischen ortskräfte geben
soll passiert etwas
merkel gibt eine woche später eine tk
ich möchte dass wir hier denen die uns
sehr stark gewesen haben auch wirklich
einen ausweg geben und jetzt nach diesem
machtwort von merkel passiert jetzt was
sie hat ja schließlich die
richtlinienkompetenz als kanzlerin also
statt sich um flüge aus afghanistan zu
kümmern sorgt sich auch seehofer her um
flüge nach afghanistan um die
abschiebung straffälliger afghanen noch
anfang august der abschiebe flug wird
nur deshalb storniert weil zu diesem
zeitpunkt in afghanistan ein schwerer
anschlag passiert und die botschaft den
berlinern klar macht dass die situation
im land so ist dass man nicht mehr ab
leben kann schrill und jetzt dann also
die alarmglocken in berlin
immer noch nicht erst als die amerikaner
in kabul die sogenannte green soll
verlassen dort wo die botschaft beseelt
erst dann ist klar dass kabul feld und
trotzdem selbst in diesem dramatischen
moment als menschen in afghanistan hier
in deutschland bei uns anrufen und um
hilfe flehen verzweifelt versuchen in
den inneren bereich des kabuler
flughafens zu kommen selbst in diesem
moment schaffen es manche politiker in
berlin nicht die ganze dramatik der
situation und des eigenen versagens
realistisch wahrzunehmen armin laschet
der cdu kanzler kandidat sagt am montag
nach dem fall von kabul das europäische
union muss sich darauf vorbereiten
dass es
flüchtlingsbewegungen richtung europa
geben könnte
2015 darf sich nicht wiederholen und
auch sein parteifreund gerd müller von
der csu der minister für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit hält es in diesem moment
für angebracht dass sein ministerium den
eigenen horz kräften in afghanistan
erklärt dass man nur die familien
aufnehmen nicht aber erwachsene söhne
noch mehr dass man versucht die eigenen
ortskräfte zum bleiben in afghanistan zu
überreden mit sogenannten bleibeprämien
und jetzt erleben wir in berlin das was
ich immer lebe wenn dinge richtig schief
laufen einerseits berliner krisen-pr die
funktioniert so dass man möglichst wenig
über die eigenen fehler die eigene
verantwortung redet und möglichst viel
handelt nach vorne richtet den blick und
sich als entschlossenen entscheider
darstellt genau der oder die die man
vorher nicht wahr das heißt man versucht
die eigenen fehler zu überschreiben mit
neuen news von starken handeln und die
ministerien versuchen sich hinter den
kulissen den schwarzen peter
zuzuschieben man nennt das das blame
game in berlin und genau das passiert im
moment auch es ist ja schließlich
wahlkampf ich will nicht ausweichen ich
will aber auch nicht mit einem finger
auf andere zeigen sie müssen auf die zu
gehen mit denen reden die eigentlich für
ihre fragen zuständig sind wie bei allen
anderen krisen und desastern die wir in
den letzten monaten erleben mussten ist
der apparat in berlin mal wieder vor
allem mit sich selbst beschäftigt mit
hakeleien zwischen den ministerien mit
eifersüchteleien zwischen den ministern
und mit einer kanzlerin die eigentlich
schon im abschied nehmen ist und vor
allem ihre richtlinienkompetenz nicht
wahrnimmt die auf konsens setzt und
darauf dass irgendwie alle
verantwortlich sind und damit keiner das
ist eine bittere lektion für alle die
jetzt noch aus afghanistan heraus zu
kommen versuchen ich habe euch gesagt
dass das staatsversagen ist ein massiver
verlust an glaubwürdigkeit nicht nur in
afghanistan oder in deutschland sondern
in der ganzen welt wer will uns jetzt
noch glauben wenn wir erklären dass wir
leute schützen werden in der welt dass
wir eintreten werden für sie und für
ihre rechte auf freiheit und demokratie
warum das dramatisch ist ich war fünf
jahre lang korrespondent in peking und
habe erlebt wie china mit aller macht
sein einfluss jenseits seiner grenzen
ausdehnen wenn das neue weltmacht wie es
die faszination des autoritären
exportieren will in die welt und genau
das erleben wir gerade auch in
afghanistan die botschaften die da noch
geöffnet sind also die von china und
russland
es ist also mehr als nur ein
staatsversagen gegenüber den
afghanischen orts kräften es ist ein
desaster für den westen und für die idee
von freiheit und demokratie
was da passiert ist das macht diese
staatsversagen so dramatisch